you now joining me is the former press
secretary Deborah Johnson and current
managing director of public affairs at
Adelman UK will Warden good morning to
you will Warden nice to talk to you
first of all hello did she have to go
yeah she absolutely did I mean
essentially none of her policies were
left
um her her obsession with small State uh
Britain uh you know tanked the economy
essentially and there was no way back
and once she had replaced her Chancellor
with Jeremy Hunt and he ditched all her
policies there was only one way and that
was out the door I mean I think there
probably will be very little Sympathy
For Liz truss among the public this
morning polls suggested just two percent
think she did a good job but from a
personal point of view it's an absolute
tragedy and it's a humiliation uh you
know and she will have to live with the
fact now that her place in history is
the shortest serving prime minister
she'll essentially be the answer to a
pub quiz question and that must be
terrible for her personally but you know
the country couldn't carry on as it is
and we needed a change the problem is
that I don't think there's any clarity
about what that change will look like
well yes and what's your take given that
you work closely with Boris Johnson do
you think he will try to run again
you know everyone's saying oh
um you know Johnson's in the frame he's
he's flying back I've spoken to someone
that's spoken to him and he is on the
way back and clearly he's taking
soundings but the thing about Boris is
that he absolutely hates to lose and I
suspect that if he doesn't think he can
get to the 100 or more importantly he
can he can come second in this in the in
the first boat because I think you know
Richie sunak is is clearly the front
runner then he won't run but if he does
think he can then I'm sure he will
because you know in his mind he's done
nothing wrong he's been unfairly
defenestrated whether you think that's
true or not it doesn't matter to Boris
and it's not a case of the national
interest it's a case of boris's Interest
so if he thinks that he has a chance of
winning with the members vote next week
you know then he'll run I think the
problem with that is that you know the
Tory party doesn't have a Unity
candidate and they seem to have
those that are backing him already he
seem to have forgotten very quickly
what's happened you know Boris and his
best had an elastic relationship with
the truth but if you had everything that
happened Patterson and parties and
Pinscher and the way he governed and the
fact that you know before he left there
were two horrific by-election defeats in
a way the the the beholding of Liz Trust
of the country was Boris Johnson's
responsibility and I think you know we
are we are all guilty of collective
Amnesia if we forget that six weeks ago
70 of the country consistently wanted
him out including a majority of Tory
voters and there's no evidence that
they've changed their mind there's also
no evidence that Boris has changed his
mind in terms of how he'll behave or how
he'll govern uh I think the problem for
the Tory party at the moment is that
there isn't necessarily A Unity
candidate you know I was on another
broadcaster earlier Anna and I suggested
that there was some unanimity amongst
perhaps a small majority of Tory
Adventures that Rishi sunak you know was
the front runner and could be a Unity
candidate and a very senior member of
the government texted me and said that
that's rubbish you know he's almost as
unpopular among many as as Boris Johnson
so there is no easy choice I think if
there was a Unity candidate it would be
somebody like the defense secretary Ben
Wallace I think there's two problems
there that I I get the sense that Ben
Wallace won't run uh and the other thing
is that the country doesn't know what a
Ben Wallace platform would look like so
I think it's a horrific mess and I think
they've got a week to get it right and
I'm not sure they're necessarily going
to
and is there actually such a thing as a
Unity candidate when you've got a party
that's so divided
well I think that's the problem is that
you know are they thinking in the best
interest of the conservative party or
the best interest of the of the country
and the problem is that the conservative
party is now so Riven not just with
factions but just with a sense of
identity what does it actually stand for
and the truth is the idea that we're
suddenly going to find that out in only
a week from somebody I think is is
laughable so I I think that you know
there is clearly a sense among the the
sort of governing or managing hierarchy
in the conservative party talking to
some of them that what they really need
is for
um you know this contest to have a clear
front runner and then whoever comes
second assuming it isn't Boris Johnson
um it's a fold in behind that person I
think the trouble is that's a that's a
huge ask and we don't know you know who
that person who might come second
whether they would want to fold in you
know anyone that comes second in this
contest presumed he thinks they have a
chance of winning why would they do that
and that's partly a problem with the
system of electing the next leader it's
also part here part a problem with the
fact that the Tory party has lost its
identity
and that's why I think that
unfortunately the likely outcome is that
whoever they choose
um you know that Unity will dissipate
fairly quickly and I suspect we'll end
up with a general election in pretty
short order
well will wasn't always fascinating to
get your take thanks very much indeed
for your time this morning we really do
appreciate it thanks